You had asked why did I drag you through all of these binomial distribution stuff
and flipped so many coins, the reason is you're going to move now towards
what's perhaps the most deep insight in all of statistics.
It's called the central limit theorem.
And the way I want you to get there is through a programming exercise.
Now, I told you that all the programming is optional
and you can totally skip this one but I beg you to stay with me.
What you're about to see is perhaps the most interesting way to understand
the central limit theorem and statistics of large numbers.
In assignment #1, I literally want you to flip a coin 1000 times.
And once you've done this, I want you to compute the mean of the outcome
and the standard deviation.
Flipping a coin is a random event. It gives us things like 0 or 1s as outcomes.
Like this thing over here.
If we were to do this 1000 for a fair coin, you expect the outcome of the mean to be 0.5.
You probably have no clue what to expect for the standard deviation.
There's a couple of things I want to give you.
In your programming environment, you'll find the function mean, the function variance,
and the function standard deviation as you've practiced it before.
And what if I did a little bit to make sure that whatever you do is of type float
what you need for computing the mean.
Otherwise, it might be of type integer and then these calculations all go wrong.
Same over here in the computation of the variance but ignore the float type conversion.
Other than that, it's exactly what I've shown you before.
I now want you to implement the function flip that takes this as an argument
the number of coin flips you want to do, 1000 in this case,
and then use as a function mean and then standard deviation to compute
the mean and the standard deviation of the resulting sequence of outcomes.
This will be a list filled with 0s or 1s.
The thing to know is that with the function random.random,
there's two of them with a dot in the middle, gives you a random value
that sits between 0 and 1.
Every time you call this function, you get a different random value,
which is nice because you just have to call this 1000 times to get you 1000 samples.
But then in the interval of 0 and 1 and you want to put them back into coin flips,
so what you have to do is to call this expression here.
And this expression over here will give you true or false,
which is the same for the purpose here of 1 and 0 .
It gives you true if the random value happens to be larger than 0.5 and false if it's smaller.
So the assignment is to call this thing 1000 times
and make a list of these 1000 outcomes and put that code in and the function flip
that returns that list and then you're done.
So here's a typical outcome for this code. If I run it, the mean might be 0.484.
There's the standard deviation.
If I run it again, I get a different mean of 0.51 and a different standard deviation